IslamNet is raising funds to establish a
masjid and community center in Norway
and they urgently need your support.
This donation will be a sadaqa jariya
for you because every person that comes
a step closer to Allah through your
donation, you will inshallah be reaping
the reward. Click the link and donate
what you can. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh brothers and
sisters and dear friends. Hope you guys
are well inshallah. Before I start, I
want to praise Allah subhana wa ta'ala,
the most merciful, the most just. All
praises, glory and gratitude belong to
him.
I hate to do these videos. I'll be
honest with you, these are one of those
videos I dislike so much to do um to
free myself from someone or like and
believe me, I hate it. I don't like it.
I don't like Well, whoever knows me
knows me. I don't go out and look for
people's faults. I don't go and say who
can I do this for you, this, that. Allah
is my witness. I just believe anyone
that brings harm to the ummah
intentionally or unintentionally
they might want good etc. but whatever
it is for that matter
I try my best to do my part and say this
is wrong. And I expect exactly the same
thing for myself. Exactly the same
thing. If you see me stepping up a line,
stepping out of line, if you see me
doing something call me out. I'm not a
hypocrite and I've been called out
sometimes unjustly, sometimes justly and
that's the matter. I came to Islam guys
because of tawhid. I came to Islam
because of the oneness of God. I came to
Islam because to me before I was told
about Islam, I knew God is one. He's not
a man. There's nothing like him. He is
the supreme. He is the mighty. He's the
majestic. All praises belong to him.
Okay, I I knew these things. I was I
didn't need to be told.
And this is what the fitra is and this
is what we believe that innate
disposition is. So why am I doing this
video? Now, I want to make it very clear
and I'll take an oath of Allah subhana
wa ta'ala. May Allah subhana wa ta'ala
deal with me. Wallahi I swear upon the
rub of the Kaaba. May Allah subhana wa
ta'ala deal with me, expose me
whatever it is for that matter if I have
anything against brother Daniel
personally. Anything. He knows privately
and publicly when I would have debate he
would help me with material etc. I have
nothing but love for all the brothers in
the dawah and I want nothing but for
Islam to succeed and for the kalam of
Allah to be the highest.
However
this is what I want to make that clear.
Yes, wallahi al-azim I don't have
anything personal against you brother
Daniel. Wallahi and you know that. And I
this is the reason why people come and
say, you know, he's you know,
downgrading shirk or he sound like a
shirk apologist or whatever it is for
that matter.
We waited. We waited, waited, waited to
assume the best, advise in private. Many
people doing it. Like I didn't find the
need to do because I'm not knowledgeable
on that matter. Many people spoke to him
etc.
and whatever it is for that matter. And
he has his opinion whatever it is for
that matter.
However, I hope this doesn't go down the
road like I said before I'm not planning
to do a back and forth. I want to do
this video and leave it at that. I'll be
honest with you.
I I I hope like you know, he doesn't go
down the road of calling me a Wahhabi
and a Zionist. I've been called all
kinds of stuff, a Christian, a spy, a
this, a that. I don't really care about
the words. It's just that it would
discredit him. But it's up to him. Like
if he wants to call me a Wahhabi and I'm
a Zionist and I'm this and I'm that
that's totally up to him. I'm not going
to do that and I'm going to inshallah my
aim is to this is only video and that's
it. And why am I doing this? Because I
have uh asked you guys to watch Daniel
Haqiqatjou's video. I have promoted
Daniel Haqiqatjou both privately and
publicly uh even like about a year ago
etc. when I was in Qatar uh I still
said, you know, I mentioned his name
even though there was some stuff coming
that were uh very concerning when it
comes to tawhid. I still done that. Why?
Because I have no animosity. So the
question is why am I doing this video?
I'm doing this video guys for a couple
of reasons. Uh number one to uh answer
certain misconceptions that's being
portrayed there. Uh number one the the
main main thing is the whole issue of
tawhid. The whole issue where I spoke to
him and I made a comment about a couple
of months ago on brother Farid's video
where I was shocked to hear from brother
Daniel Haqiqatjou's mouth the stuff that
he was saying.
And obviously I made a comment which I
expressed my concerns. And brother
Daniel Haqiqatjou said to me and asked
me to delete the comment. I'm Let me
make this very categorical clear. I'm
not here to put everyone out and if
Daniel or Jake or Farid or anyone else
for that matter you have an issue with
that uses video that's not my fault.
That is not my fault. Just the way you
used my comment I made on Farid's thing
in public by saying that oh I deleted
the comment because I realized that they
are
something along those lines that they
are wrong or etc. That's not true bro.
You asked me to delete the comment
Daniel. You asked me to delete it. So
you used that to advantage. So I can't
control so don't come and say to me I'm
on anyone's side. I'm on no one's side.
My loyalty is to Allah and his
messenger. So I'm not on Farid's side.
I'm not on Jake's side. I'm not on
Daniel's side. I'm not on your side. I'm
on the side of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
and his messenger and whoever fits in
that we're in it together. So I want to
make that clear. So the comment that you
said you asked me to delete while you
said that I didn't give you a chance to
express your or defend your position.
I said okay even though the videos are
clear but okay, you're right. That's a
good point and I apologize. I deleted
the comment at your request. And then I
listened to your take on and I asked you
certain questions which are the private
discussions. I do not want to make them
public.
Uh and from what I can see from my
assessment bro
what brother Farid said there's nothing
different that you said. Look, I'm
saying this with respect. I'm not trying
to say bro I asked you questions and you
said the same thing. Now I'm going to
come to that in a minute. The whole
thing. So I wanted to make that
clarification. Number two
things are getting really personal with
you and others bro. It's getting really
dangerous. These are one of the two
lesser reasons. The main thing is the
tawhid thing, the shirk thing.
You have now come out and bro you are
trying to connect Abdnan Rashid to
Abdnan Rashid Ustadh Farid
to a crime, a terrorist attack that
happened in Australia and you are
labeling them as Wahhabi. Yes, some
people call me a Wahhabi. They call me a
Salafi. They call me all kinds of names.
Okay. Uh anyway, okay. So you're now
connecting them to a terrorist attack
happened. And that to me is
like wallahi I'll be honest with you
very malicious. Because not only did
they come out and um praise the hero
Muslim hero but let's say they didn't
even do that. They were quiet about the
matter. You're going and calling them a
Wahhabi and connecting Wahhabism to a
terrorist attack and Do you know how
dangerous that is Daniel? Like you might
have issues with them. No problem. You
might have your opinion whatever it is
for that matter. To go this low bro.
Imagine if I came and said to you bro
you are connected to a Shia militia.
Hezbollah. Yes? You do this, this, this.
Do you know how dangerous that is for
you and your family bro? For me to
recklessly come out in public and say
statements and then you double down and
make another tweet. You know, and that
they are connected to that. So bro these
are dangerous stuff. Very dangerous. I
was shocked. That's not my main concern.
Like the shirk the stuff that you're
saying about pertaining to certain
things not being shirk which we're going
to come to later about sacrificing for
the jinn's uh not being shirk, 99.9%
being shirk for the
the imams or prophets or whatever
controlling the atoms uh for that We'll
come to that and then the other stuff
that you said to me where where I spoke
to you and I asked you direct questions.
We're going to come to that later. My
main concern is that these I would
prefer you to be um saying that these
guys are Wahhabis. I'll prefer you doing
1 million tweets about that and public
videos than you saying that these things
are not shirk. We'll come to that in a
minute inshallah. So I want to make that
disclaimer and say brother Daniel,
wallahi
please these are dangerous things.
You're putting people's lives in danger
bro. They can get stopped and be
questioned. Would you like it if I
started a smear campaign because I had a
difference with you whatever and said
you're connected to Hezbollah and Shia.
That's
as worse you get stopped on your way
traveling etc. It's not nice bro. You've
got a family. You've got a kid. You can
have your differences. Respectfully go
ahead with that. There's a way I'm doing
it with you bro. I don't Look, I'm not
calling you names. I have nothing but
ask Allah's guidance for you and myself.
So that's been said and cleared out the
way let's get to the main issue of why I
have no choice but to free myself from
you
and I do not mean this in any
disrespect. I do not mean this I'm
better than you. Genuinely bro I believe
what you're calling to is absolutely so
dangerous.
And it just takes the essence of what's
the point of Allah? Why do we need Allah
if you believe these things? If this
person go to from him, you know, he and
I and I said this to you. He's the all
knowing. He's the all seeing with the
permission of Allah. He's the
al-hakim with the permission of Allah.
He's the provider and sustainer with the
permission of Allah.
Why do we need to go to Allah? What's
what's what's unique about Allah? If a
prophet can do all of those not
independently by depending on Allah.
Yeah people why do we go to Allah for
what? For what? If I go to a manager and
the manager can give me everything to
see okay. I don't want to see the CEO
bro. What's the what's the need for the
CEO? The manager I'm fine with the
manager bro. What's the point of seeing
the CEO? For what? Yeah? And this is the
the the the crux of the matter. This is
the issue at hand and I believe this is
very very dangerous and you are pushing
that out there and you're belittling and
degrading it bro. It's as if me Imagine
we know I come and say look zina is
haram. It's a major sin. It's a major
sin. It's a major sin. It's a major sin.
However, some scholars said, you know,
da da da this, that or whatever
whatever. If I keep talking about yeah
zina is not that bad. It's a major sin
but it's not that bad. Some people
commit zina because they have no choice
to. Some people commit zina because um
uh they might want to commit
pornography. Some people do zina
argument's sake. If I keep doing this
you're going to say this guy is a zina
apologist. You know what I mean? You're
making it seem as if Okay, okay. I'm
going to say it's a major sin but
you talk in a way where you're
belittling and degrading shirk out of
everything bro. Out of everything. So
let's get straight into the reaction
videos to understand why I believe this
is very very dangerous. So guys, so
let's react to the first video of
brother Daniel Haqiqatjou
um and see what he has to say on this
matter. starts thinking about Jesus
while Jesus is a prophet and Jesus had
these different miracles. He could cure
the sick
uh by the power of Allah, by the will of
Allah.
So Jesus is like a wali. Jesus is like a
saint.
And I'm going to pray to Jesus.
Uh I'm going to do istighatha to the
saint
to Jesus to heal my leprosy. Oh Jesus,
heal my leprosy.
This is istighatha. So he The word is
the The wording is the same. The dua is
the same.
The only thing that has been that is
different is his beliefs.
Right? Because before he believed that
Jesus is God. After he believes that
Jesus
is a wali.
The Salafis who say that istighatha and
praying to the prophet or praying to
Jesus is shirk akbar like what Jake
claims and what all these other people
are claiming
if it's shirk Akbar, that means it's
exactly like the dua that he was making
when he was a Christian. So, if you guys
notice, Daniel says that because it's
lesser in severity, therefore it doesn't
equate to shirk. But, I mean we have
many many examples. For example, one of
the prophets when the Prophet was with
one of the companions, yes, and the
companion used to be a Jew. Yes, and he
said, "Did you not take you your rabbis
as your lords?" And he said, "Oh, but
Allah, we never like
worshiped them or something." He said,
"Did you not take what's halal halal and
what's haram haram when they did
istihlal?" He said, "Yes." He said,
"That's what I'm talking about." So, in
this instance, uh shirk is not just
someone going and bowing down to an
idol. Okay, we know very clearly when
Allah says, "Have you seen the one who
takes his desires as his own god?" Yes,
so we know it comes in different forms.
So, to come and say this severity or
that severity uh
doesn't make one shirk, it's it's absurd
to me. Okay, so now let's go to the
second reaction video of what brother
Daniel says. Like this is a deviant
position to follow 12 imams and to
consider that to be the basis of of
Islam, that is deviance, but does it
reach kufr? That's the question. For
some it does, and for some it doesn't.
If you just say that, "Oh, if you
believe that your imam uh has this kind
of insight or your imam like has these
kinds of supernatural powers, that makes
you a kafir," then guess what? A lot of
Sunnis become kuffar because of that uh
that principle. A lot of Sunni Muslims
will say that the Prophet Muhammad
controls the universe and there's not an
atom that moves without the control of
the Prophet Muhammad.
So, if one is kufr, the other one is
kufr. If one is a kafir, the other is a
kafir.
Be consistent, you know, in in your
takfir. I mean, I agree with brother
Daniel Hakachu for that matter. Yes,
he's saying be consistent. Okay, no
problem. From our perspective, we don't
I don't know any Sunni that believes
that the Prophet controls the atoms etc.
of the universe. Let's go with it. Let's
suppose that's the case. Yes, let's be
consistent. So, it's not a matter of
being Sunni, Shia, Barelvi, Ash'ari,
Deobandi, whatever it is for that
matter. Anyone that believes a prophet
or a human being controls atoms of the
universe or controls the weather or
controls this or controls that, for that
matter, we believe that is a form of
shirk. So, yes, I agree. We should be
consistent and we'll be consistent.
Whoever it is for that matter, it takes
you out the fold of Islam to give an
attribute that belongs to Allah Ta'ala
to the creation. Period. Not 99.9%
shirk, 100% shirk. You have agreed to
defend this position of that the the
creation can control the atoms. So, the
question that I want to ask brother
Daniel is, which I find a little bit
bizarre, is that you say okay that
you don't believe this is not your
position that the the creation controls
atoms or
for that matter, but then you come and
you're debating it. I'm I'm a little bit
like I don't understand what's the logic
and rationale behind that. If you don't
believe in the position, why are you
defending it?
Why I don't understand what is the
benefit of defending it? If I come and
say, "I believe zina is a major sin.
However, I'm going to debate that, you
know, for example, there are opinions
that say that
Brother, if I if my position is that
zina is a major sin, why am I coming and
putting a shubha hat or putting
something there that somebody can take
and think, "Hmm, maybe in my situation
zina might be okay or I can go around
and maybe Brother, zina, if it's a major
sin, if Allah says don't go near it,
then let's me leave it at that. We're
debating it is opening the door to one
side saying, "Hmm, he made some good
points. Hmm, he did it." So, you're
opening that door. So, I'm genuinely
asking, why are you debating a topic
that you don't hold that position to,
bro? It's a It's a It's a waste of time.
So, in this next reaction video, guys,
we're going to be watching Daniel
Hakachu trying to tell us how it is okay
to ask saints to give you kids and other
stuff for that matter. Let's watch for
ourselves. Someone that does it that
says, "Oh, prophet or oh saint Abdul
Qadir al-Jilani oh Abdul Qadir al-Jilani
give me
children.
Give me wealth.
That is
very likely very likely that is shirk.
But, can I say that that is the same
level of shirk as a Hindu calling to
Brahma
or Shiva?
Is that the same as like a mushrik
from the Quraysh calling to Lat or Uzza?
Is it the same level? Is it the same
exact thing?
That's the question.
And I think that it's not the same.
There is a difference.
There is a difference even if it's
slight such that, okay, you know, I'll
say that it's
it's 99.999%
shirk depending on these different
factors. Okay, I mean, I'll be honest
with you guys, this this makes my jaw
drop. Like and I agree with him. It's
not the same thing.
Cuz one is a Muslim doing shirk and the
other one is a Hindu doing shirk. I
agree.
One is a Muslim doing the shirk and the
other is a mushrik doing the shirk. But,
for some reason brother Daniel thinks
that because a Muslim has a belief in
Allah, but if you look into the Quran,
then Allah says, you know, if you ask
the mushrikin, "Who created heavens and
earth?" Allah. "Who created this?"
Allah. Allah.
It's clearly the Quran is clearly
telling you the mushrik believed that.
They believed in Allah some at least to
some point. So, what does that mean now?
So, does that mean that as a Muslim
myself, brother Daniel and those who are
watching, I'm a Muslim, I'm a revert to
Islam, I believe in Allah and his
messenger, I believe in everything, but
I go and say, "You know what? I'm going
to make dua and I'm going to ask
some guy, some saint. Yeah, and I'm
going to say, "No, I please give me some
children." It doesn't matter. Oh, but
after I do dawah, is it the same thing?
Like look, I do dawah, I've been calling
to Islam for 13 years. Yep, I have I've
been Give me the credit, guys. I've been
calling to Islam. I'm in the dawah. My
name is Ali Dawah. It's in my name as
well. I'm a Muslim. I pray my salah. I
give my sadaqah. I do Okay. Me doing
shirk is not as bad as the mushrik
because he's a mushrik. I call the
dawah. I'm so sorry. I don't care what
you call to. It's not about what you
are. It's what you are doing. It's that
action that you're doing. It's not your
status of who you are. It's rather what
you do. So, this is why it amazes me.
When I saw the video from brother Farid,
that's why I left that comment cuz I was
absolutely amazed cuz I'm not following
what's going back and forth with all due
respect. Yeah, I don't know who's doing
what before brother Daniel comes and
says, "Well, he's done that." Forget all
of that. I'm just saying I was shocked.
And then I gave brother Daniel the
chance to explain himself. I spoke to
him, asked him questions, and he said
the same thing that's been said on the
video.
It's been said. So,
to me, that is dangerous. Shirk is the
most dangerous thing, guys. Don't go
near it if there's 1% chance. You know
how brother Daniel says, "It's 99%
shirk, but not ultimately." I'm saying,
guys, if there's 1% shirk, don't go near
it. Not 99%, 1%. Okay, guys, so the next
video we're going to react to is
pertaining to uh
In a nutshell, Daniel Hakachu is saying
using the brother of
Sheikh ibn Abdul Wahhab that his brother
is saying that sacrificing to a jinn
is not shirk Akbar.
Let's watch a video for ourselves. Let's
look at the quoted passages that Farid
focuses on. Sulaiman ibn Abdul Wahhab
says, "As far as sacrificing to other
than Allah, it's held under the status
of haram actions. It's not classed as
major kufr unless the sacrifice is done
to idols or what is worshipped besides
Allah." Sulaiman ibn Abdul Wahhab is
saying here that if you sacrifice for a
pagan idol, that is shirk Akbar. But, if
you sacrifice to someone other than
Allah but not an idol, then that is
haram and does not reach the level of
shirk Akbar. So, guys, you saw that for
yourselves and I mean, what can we say?
You know, if you look at the idols, the
mushrikin that they worshipped, and
these are individuals that represented
people. The idols represented the
saints. So, even when you look into the
Quran, clearly Allah tells us that the
jinn were taken as worshipping
worshipping them besides Allah Ta'ala.
So, even then the argument doesn't make
sense. And if brother Farid at least
Farid is consistent in saying, "Yes,
anyone that says this, whoever it is, if
Sheikh Abdul Wahhab
comes out and says the same thing, we'll
say the same thing to him." So, I see
consistency at least in that specific
part. So, if somebody comes out and says
that sacrificing to a jinn is not shirk,
yes, we believe it's uh sacrificing is a
form of ibadah. And if somebody
sacrifices other than to Allah Ta'ala,
it is shirk. So, if somebody sacrifices
in the name of Jesus, it's shirk. Stay
away from it. This is the only sin that
Allah says he will not forgive forgive.
Like Allah says in the Quran like I told
you guys before, Allah says they took
the jinn as associates besides Allah
Ta'ala. Now, Daniel is not coming and
saying, you know, he's he's he's clearly
saying that it is haram, it's not shirk.
And again, it goes back to my point,
guys. If we was here, if somebody was
talking about Let's suppose, for
example, people committing zina. Yes, in
in the UK, whatever it is for that
matter. And brother came out and said,
"Zina is haram, it's a major sin. It's
that that Yeah, but let's have a
debate." But, is it shirk though? Is
zina shirk though? No, it's not. But,
it's haram. I know it's haram. But, is
it shirk though? He's going to say,
"Brother, like what's your point? Yeah,
it's not shirk." See? It's not shirk.
It's just It's just a major sin. Yeah,
habibi, but it's it's it's something
that's haram and many people and Allah
said it's a major Yeah, I know. I'm not
denying that it's a major sin, bro. I'm
just saying, is it shirk though?
Brother, if I turn videos over and over
again saying, "But, it's not about the
shirk. It's not about the shirk. It's
not about the shirk." You guys will
start People who are committing zina
will come and say, "You know what? Yeah,
we do commit zina. But, it's not shirk."
Do you see what the problem is? The
problem is when you come with this
rhetoric and you keep repeating it, you
are belittling, yes, you are undermining
what shirk is.
And that's my point. It's It's not shirk
though. Yes, I I drink alcohol, but it's
not shirk though, bro. Yes, but I I I
sell prostitution, but it's not shirk,
but you're you're good. It's not shirk.
It's a major sin, but it's not shirk.
The terminology we use is dangerous. And
like the Prophet said, "Speech can be
like sihr." And I'm not saying brother
Daniel is this on purpose or not. I'm
just saying it is dangerous." Another
vital key thing that I want to point out
guys is the double standards here, yeah?
And like I said before, I'm just trying
to be just here. Allah says in the
Quran, "Be just even if it's against
against yourself or your kin." The video
that I'm going to show you guys is
brother Daniel Haqiqatjou's video from
5-6 years ago of brother Omar Suleiman.
Yes? And if we watch it, you can see
that he was involved in some kind of a
protest that was happening and he didn't
know. He made it clear he did not know
it's some kind of a ritual, whatever
matter, pouring water on the sand or
whatever for that matter. But Daniel
Haqiqatjou had no mercy on him. He gave
him no good assumptions, nothing. He was
brutal and he accused him of kufri acts.
Okay? Which you can give a good
assumption because he did not know. Yes,
we can say the act is kufr, but Omar
Suleiman still Omar Suleiman made it
very clear he did not know or he said I
was not involved. But I want you guys to
watch the video and let's come and talk
about it a bit more, inshallah. Instead,
we call out to them with love.
That you have a right to seek peace.
You have a right TO SEEK ASYLUM.
YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO NOT BE TEAR GASSED.
YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO BE HONORED and
dignified.
Subhanallah, I'm having trouble
expressing my anger and disgust
at
this. I mean
a prominent Imam
participating in a pagan ritual.
Like
it just boggles my mind that any Muslim
would take their deen from someone like
this.
And let's not forget that this happened
in front of hundreds of people. And this
was the main deal. This was the main
show to bless the migrants. To bless the
migrants. This ritual was the whole
purpose, the culmination of this Sunnah
protest. And there is an Imam supposedly
representing Muslims who is there at
front engaging in outright kufr. So, and
I want this to be consistent, okay,
brother Daniel? Just the way you said
you were in disgust, why would anyone
take the religion from an Imam like
that? Okay? And this is kufr.
Brother Daniel, you have to be
consistent. Like I said before, I'm not
trying to have the exact I'm not trying
to be sly. I'm genuinely saying, bro,
why is that video still up, bro? You owe
owe Omar Suleiman an apology. Because if
you believe that we should not take
religion from him you if you believe
that that is disgusting, if you believe
that's kufr, which I agree it is, but he
very clearly said he did not know. We
can give him the good benefits of
benefit of doubt. Yes? However, with
yourself, brother Daniel, you are doing
videos, planning them, and you do it and
you come out and say
it's not shirk, it's haram. It's not my
view.
I'm just saying you're blurring the
lines between tawhid and shirk. We have
every right to feel disgusted about
that. We have a right to just come and
say that people should not take
knowledge from you being consistent. And
we can come and say that is statements
of kufr.
We have every right to say that.
And I don't know why that video is still
up, bro, because you have to be
consistent, bro. If that's kufr, then
sacrificing for the jinn
should be kufr. Yes? You've changed your
position now, okay? Or saying that you
don't you don't believe that but you're
putting it out there. Um saying that the
Imams or the prophets control the atoms
in the universe and this and that. They
can they can with the permission of
Allah, not independently. Yes? Okay,
that's kufr. Yes? Um saying that you can
make your putting a teacher out in
Furry's video saying that you can make
dua, you can ask the Prophet Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam himself. He
he can say, "Oh yeah, oh Muhammad, grant
me children, protect me." Yes?
Isn't that kufr?
You have to be consistent, bro. You have
to be consistent. If that is the case,
why is that video still up, bro? You owe
Ustad Omar Suleiman an apology.
And as much as you are disgusted, you
have to understand that we are disgusted
by certain statements that you say, bro.
As much as you warned against Omar
Suleiman, which I believe unjustly,
we have a right to come and say we're
doing this video, nothing malicious,
nothing personal, but it's purely for
the sake of Allah. Yes? And we have a
right to come and say the statement
you're saying is kufr.
To be consistent. So, again, and I'm
going to end on this note, guys. I've
said in the beginning and I took off by
Allah I have nothing personal against
brother Daniel, but I have to free
myself because number one I have to be
consistent and number two I believe in
tawhid and I believe in the oneness of
Allah. And I don't believe anyone should
risk their akhirah over this matter. Why
do we debate the Christians for so much?
Why do we do it? And if we're going to
use the argument of
yes, but they don't independently do it.
Yeah, habibi, then what is the point of
Allah? Please, I'm asking anyone that's
watching this, why do we need Allah if
the Prophet Muhammad
or Jesus, Moses, Ibrahim, all of them,
if they have the powers of answering my
dua, if they have the powers of
my risk, if they have the powers of
controlling the universe,
okay, let's let's the argument say the
Prophet
he has he is the all-knowing, not by
himself, with the power of Allah. He's
the all-seeing, the all-hearing. Okay.
Okay, what what do I need Allah for?
Please, can you tell me? I want this
question answered, please. What do I
need Allah for if the Prophet
is the all-wise, the all-knowing, the
all-powerful, the ever-providing?
What's what's what's what's what's
what's the uniqueness of Allah? What's
what's Please, can you tell me? I want
to know. This is why, guys, I just want
to strongly and strongly say
I ask Allah to guide myself, guide
brother Daniel, and I'm going to leave
this matter at that. I do not wish to go
back and forth.
If he decides to call me a Zionist, it's
fine. I've been called worse. I'm a
Wahhabi. I don't mind. Call me whatever
you like. It's fine. What I'm just
saying is my position is clear on this
matter. I ask Allah to guide brother
Daniel Haqiqatjou back to the haqq,
inshallah. And that's it, nothing
personal.
Nothing I said before, his debates and
discussion with the Christians
are commendable, but it defeats the
purpose when you're trying to refute
someone who believes Jesus is God, but
then you come and say these things which
I mean what's the difference? What's the
difference? You might say, "Oh, but they
they say Jesus is God, but yeah, but
brother, you're doing the same thing."
That's all I want to say, inshallah.
There's nothing else I can say. Brothers
and sisters, let me Allah guide you guys
and guide myself, inshallah. And I hope
this video clarifies my position on this
matter once and for all. Till next time.
Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.